you've got to be one insufferable
villain
to make kittens look bad because you
know
deep down you deserve to be punished
there are some bad guys that we can't
help but feel a shred of pity for
but these agonizing antagonists don't
fall into that category
with zero mercy pityless backstories and
actions that make us want to slap our tv
screens
these villains and the actors that play
them are terrific
at being terrifying
dolores umbridge is the most hated
villain in harry potter
and she's got some tough competition she
actually makes us hate
cats and the color pink and to make
matters worse
she's a total buzz kill it's hard to see
imelda staunton's face without thinking
of the insufferable witch she plays
every time she opens her mouth that
sickly sweet voice makes us clench our
fists and wait impatiently for karma to
get her
that ought to be prohibited
it's easy to hate umbridge because she's
so annoyingly patronizing and righteous
plus we never find out why she's like
that we don't even feel bad when she
gets carried away by centaurs
game of thrones has its fair share of
irredeemable characters
so you've got to be really terrible to
stand out as the worst of the worst
to joffrey being evil is second nature
he's somehow worse than his entire
messed up family
who have spoiled him and created this
privileged monster
but what's most frustrating is that he
acts like the victim before using his
power to get revenge on people
or direwolves we hated him so much that
when he was poisoned
most of us celebrated it's still hard to
see jack gleason without remembering how
much we despise joffrey's indignant
smirk
president snow is an evil mastermind who
keeps us on the edge of our seats as
katniss tries to overthrow his
oppressive regime
snow looks down on and intimidates
everyone
and donald sutherland provides that
sophisticated kind of evil necessary to
make him both respectable and
terrifying he seems to know everything
like his enemy's weakness
and is always plotting and issuing
thinly veiled threats
even with a whole book about his
backstory we still can't help but hate
him and we'll never think of white roses
the same way
13 reasons why might focus on
forgiveness but not when it comes to
bryce walker
he acts like a guy who wants to feel bad
but he can't really bring himself to
which means we never truly pity him
eventually bryce apologizes for his many
crimes
but it feels like he's doing the least
he can to make himself
feel better he lies and makes excuses
for his actions
i i know i'm sorry like a privileged boy
who thinks he can do whatever he wants
without consequences
which is what makes him so frustrating
but at least justin prentice is
excellent at portraying the can do no
wrong attitude
david tennant only appears as barty
crouch jr for long enough to make us
absolutely hate him and his conniving
ways
barty's manic expression and completely
chaotic energy makes us want to shove
him in the chest where he hit moody
tennant nails that crazy cult-like
personality
but that's not surprising tennant
brought similar evil energy to the role
of
impenetrable mastermind kilgrave in
jessica jones which just goes to show
that he's really good at being evil
maybe too good kylian murphy
set a new bar for super villains as dr
jonathan crane
aka scarecrow in batman begins
murphy manages to act more sinister than
the film's lead villain played by liam
neeson
and it's thanks to his unsettling vibe
and how he just barely holds on to his
slipping sanity
he's not just a campy over-the-top comic
villain but
actually scary and it takes a lot of
skill to make a burlap sack
seem that terrifying
narnia is a world deserving of an epic
fantasy villain
and if you watched the movies as a kid
you probably had plenty of nightmares
about the malevolent white witch
there are many reasons to both hate and
fear her
she's manipulative plotting a ruthless
dictator full of power
and takes out her anger on animals tilda
swinton manages to straddle the line
between an approachable queen and a
villain just waiting to stab you in the
back which makes us feel anxious
every time she gets too close to one of
the kids
inglorious bastards is about some of the
most villainous people in history
and christoph waltz brings his excellent
acting skills
to the terrifying role of hans landa
someone with absolutely
no mercy or remorse hans is one of the
most
unsettling villains ever who seems truly
excited by the evil things he gets to do
his bone-chilling voice how much fun he
has with being evil
and that cool as a cucumber ability to
take a life
just demonstrates how powerful he is and
we're always questioning how much he
really knows
and when he'll strike next
with those unsettling eyes and that
alarming grin
twilight's arrow volturi stands out
amongst powerful vampires as the most
dangerous
and perhaps wackiest of them all michael
sheen's the guy behind those creepy
contacts
and extra pale skin but he's almost
unrecognizable as the kooky blood sucker
arrow makes everyone uncomfortable even
when he's just correcting their spelling
and his laugh instantly makes our skin
crawl
arrow gives off this air of power and
you're instantly sure he knows
everything
which he does since he can read thoughts
and memories with just a touch
titanic really only has one villain we
hate
well if you don't count the iceberg sure
cal hockley is frustrating and full of
himself throughout
the movie but it's really when he grabs
a child
to get a spot on that lifeboat and save
himself that we absolutely hate him
cal's really just a spoiled rich guy
putting his life above everyone else's
it's a character prime for hatred and
billy zane is awesome at acting like the
privileged man child and misogynist that
makes us root for jack
even more
bellatrix lestrange is one of the most
terrifying and frustrating characters in
the harry potter
universe just listen to that mocking
voice itsy
bitty baby
or recall her complete lack of remorse
and the sinister excitement that helena
bottom carter is
uprooted getting across with her crazy
eyes bellatrix is so evil
that voldemort actually has to keep her
under control
not only is she the one responsible for
wiping out some of our favorite
characters
like sirius and dobby but there's also
no real reason why
she decided to be so epically evil
there are plenty of reasons to hate
perry from big little lies
like trauma manipulation and the fact
that there are kids involved he acts
like the perfect husband but behind
closed doors the truth rears its ugly
head
he's a terrible person wrapped in a
pretty package but what makes us really
hate him is that even after he finally
gets what's coming to him he still ends
up traumatizing these powerful women
as gus in breaking bad giancarlo
esposito
was the kind of villain who we were more
than happy to see get his face melted
off
he brought the same villainous energy to
the role of ceo stan edgar in the boys
but what we really want to talk about is
moff gideon he's calm
and cold and we can't help but feel
chills down our spine when we know he's
on the hunt
it doesn't help that he's after the
child and he better keep his evil hands
off our favorite little green guy
moth gideon's not about to have a
full-on meltdown
but his quiet villainy makes us wonder
what terrible plan he's cooking up next
tom riddle is a boy with unfortunate
circumstances who ends up becoming
terrible
but once he splits his soul and becomes
lord voldemort
there's nothing left of the young wizard
to redeem ray finds is perfect as the
crazy but calculated dark wizard
he doesn't show mercy like when he tells
peter to get rid of cedric
and only cares about his end goal the
cherry on top is his
huge ego and unquenchable thirst for
power
which makes us feel like voldemort can
do anything he wants and get away with
it
she's just a kid but what bryony does in
atonement just feels so evil
and ruins lives and we can't help but
feel a lot of anger towards this girl
who let her jealousy get the best of her
bryony has a sense of entitlement is
envious and lives by her own sense of
morality
but her act of jealousy goes way too far
it's hard to believe a kid would stick
by a lie even after seeing someone get
carted off for a crime they didn't
commit
but bryony's plan seemed so purposefully
evil that it took a lot of sarcerone in
movies for us to believe she wasn't
going to betray
all of her co-stars which of these
actors make the best villain
let us know in the comments don't forget
to hit that like button and subscribe to
the things for more thanks for watching